las escenas de destrucción vistas estos
días en las islas de martinica y
guadalupe obligaron a dar marcha atrás
al gobierno francés el ministerio de
salud anunció el congelamiento temporal
de la medida de la vacuna obligatoria a
los trabajadores sanitarios de estas
islas y es que departamentos como el de
martinica llevan días viviendo protestas
violentas por este motivo en las calles
de la isla se suceden las barricadas y
los comercios saqueados e incluso la
residencia del más alto representante de
la francia metropolitana fue atacada
siento desolación e incomprensión por el
hecho de que la gente esté destruyendo
para divertirse
las familias están impactadas y no se
dan cuenta de los esfuerzos que ponemos
para emprender esto se hizo más bajo de
foco
con mi poco pan significa tiempo energía
sacrificio nuestras familias a veces
sacrificamos a nuestros hijos es una
lástima
hasta tengo más de la desolación la
violencia proviene del rechazo de una
parte de la población hacia las vacunas
en las últimas horas se han llegado a
reportar ataques con armas de fuego a
policías algo que ha motivado la
implantación del toque de queda desde
este jueves aquí la condena desde parís
y jamón necesitamos diálogo también me
estoy mezclando diferentes temas pero
estas personas que están provocando
disturbios que están atacando a las
fuerzas de seguridad socialistas otros
franceses tienen un comportamiento
inaceptable y debe ser enfrentado con
firmeza las protestas contra la
vacunación obligatoria comenzaron en
guadalupe para después extenderse a
martinica muchos de los manifestantes
consideraban esta cuestión como un
retroceso a la época de la esclavitud
por no poder decidir